[Musique]
bonsoir les enfants vous savez nounours
a pris de grandes résolutions dealer
nounours je leur dis voilà je ne
tricherai plus jamin fois de l'ours
c'est si vilain de tricher canton et
c'est encore plus laid ne trichez à
l'école mais ce soir nous allons jouer à
un jeu qui va faire très plaisir à
nicolas rôle gardez pas trop qu'est ce
que c'est un tout petit siffler nicolas
va être bien surpris je vais sifflet n'a
que lui à mon échelle des accessoires
ont besoin au jeu de dames à la boskoop
bredle beau soir nicolas mon petit
nicolas j'ai une surprise pour toi
nous allons faire un concours qu'est ce
que ça veut dire nous
vous allez voir nous siffler ont chacun
à notre tour et celui qui sifflent
lemieux aura connu une hausse
et oui aux no l'ours
qu'est-ce qui commande
tu n'es pas très doué pas preneur elle
siffle comme ici et moi tu vas voir nos
alors à toi mon gros nounours c'est pas
mal
nicolas mais écoute un peu comme je
siffle mois suivent le bien
[Rires]
ouais c'est pour mal c'est toi qui
suivent les limiers watts on gagnait
merci merci les enfants mais il est
l'heure d'aller au lit qu'est-ce que je
bannis grassi fleure bon animé petit
veux tu peux plus t'arrêter sifflé non
mais c'est comme ça c'est gros mais oui
c'est grand au secours
pas trop on se fie aux pauvres une bonne
nuit nicolas fait pour est apprenez
[Musique]
nuit les enfants mais mais que se
passe-t-il dont patron au secours mais
qu'y a t'il mandon nous danserons ce
grave
hollande le nours ne fait pas le bébé et
autres sifflets à la bouche
merci patron je suis sauvé là j'avais
oublié que j'avais ainsi fait dans la
bouche quand je suis bête a tout tué le
plus gros nigaud que je connaisse
on ne met jamais un sifflet dans la
bouche si tu l'avais avaler tu aurais
été très malade ça grince ça
on y va un patron en route nounours ben
nuit les enfants ne fait jamais comme
nounours
bonne nuit
atta
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
où
[Musique]